Assalamu alaykum.
Walaykum. Asalamu.
My name is Omar. I'm from Bangalore,
India. I work as an operations manager.
I have a young daughter whom I want to
admit into an Islamic school. The
Islamic school is very far from my home.
We have a convent school right beside
our home. My wife argues that we put her
in the convent school as it is close to
our home. She cites reasons such as it
is unsafe to send a girl child far
nowadays. But I want to put her in an
Islamic school so that she can stay away
from shik have an Islamic environment
and at the same time gain worldly
progress. I do not mind risking her
sending far away. I have faith in Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala that he will protect
her if I strive in his way. How do I
convince my wife? Brother Umare has
asked a very good question that he wants
to send his young child the young
daughter to an Islamic school. But the
wife is insisting that since the Islamic
school is very far, better put in a
school which is close by even though
it's convent because it's not safe to
put the child in a school which is far
away. Basically, let me tell you that
Bangalore is a safe city.
Bangalore is not like Manhattan or New
York or Bronx or you know it's a safe
city. I've been to Bangalore many times.
I have many friends. So if your child is
going to school, she's going to go at
daytime. So I don't think so it is
unsafe to send your daughter to a school
which is far away. It may be half an
hour, it may be 1 hour. see to it that
you arrange a proper transportation
whether it be a school bus whether it be
a proper vehicle which is secure I don't
think so it is risky but what you have
to realize that I do agree with omare
your husband because he is striving for
the akar imagine if you're putting your
daughter in a convent school and she
starts believing that Jesus is god or
she starts worshiping Jesus Christ peace
be upon him will you be able to forgive
yourself. You know many of time people
give the excuse that the school is far
therefore I'm not sending maybe they are
more impressed by the standard of the
convent school as compared to Islamic
schools but I'm aware that alhamdulillah
in Bangalore there are many Islamic
schools you have a lot of options you
can surely choose the school you feel
has a better standard which is more
close to Quran and sunnah and even if
hypothetically if the standard is less
than the convent school which is close
to your house it is preferable and safer
to put your child whether a daughter or
a son an Islamic school rather than a
convent school because there are high
chances that your child may go away far
from Judin. So I do agree with Omar that
and I completely support him and I would
like to remind the sister that please
don't be so much relaxed and not at all
worried about putting your child in a
convent school. There are high dangers
that they may go far away from the dean.
It is more dangerous than the danger
you're thinking that's unsafe for a girl
to travel because if she goes far away
from the dean that is multiple times
more dangerous, more harmful, more
unislamic than talking about the safety
of your child. So please I request
sister that see to it that and Allah is
there to protect you if you and I do
agree with the statement of omare that
if he's striving in the way of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala surely Allah will
protect and Bangalore is a safe city how
many cases have you heard that young
girls going in Bangalore to school which
are far they have got problem hardly any
cases so and even if it's far and if
it's tiring
Allah will support you. You'll get a
better ajar. And one more thing, it's
good for you also because the beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that when a person dies only three
things continue as sabaria. One is the
wealth that you have spent in his way.
One is the knowledge that you spread
about him about the dean and the third
is pious children praying for you. So if
your child is pious and prays for you,
you will benefit. If your child is not
pious then it will get no benefit for
you in the aar. So it will not only
benefit the child, it will benefit you
also if you put in a good authentic
Islamic school. Hope that answers the
question.